[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
successor show that will air in 2022 on
hbo
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood
volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
the man who started it all king aegon
the first targaryen known as aegon the
conqueror
and aegon the dragon was the founder and
the first king of the targaryen dynasty
which lasted for 300 years when he
conquered all of westeros
and united the realm with the exception
of dorne and the lands beyond the wall
the two sister wives and their three
great dragons
valerian vegar and marxis aegon's dragon
was balerion the black dread
the largest dragon ever seen in westeros
valerian's jaws were so large
that he could swallow a mammoth aegon
was a child of house targaryen
dwelling on the island of dragonstone in
the narrow sea
the targaryens of family of valyrian
origin
had been in control of dragonstone for a
century before the doom of valyria
destroyed their homeland in a volcanic
cataclysm
for another hundred years on dragonstone
the targaryen slowly built up their
strength
and raised their dragons the last in the
world aegon was born on dragonstone in
27 bc
the lord aryan targaryen and lady of
elena valerian
all of the previous six generations of
targaryens born in dragonstone were the
product of
incestuous marriages batarion had no
sisters
although by marrying gabilarian he still
ensured that his children were of pure
valyrian descent
he had an older sister visenya and the
younger sister rhaenys
according to targaryen and valyrian
tradition aegon married within the
family
however instead of taking only one
sister to wife as had been common
he'd married both of them aegon was tall
broad-shouldered and powerful in
appearance
with purple eyes and shortcut silver
gold hair
he was very charismatic and commanding
during his conquest he typically wore a
shirt of black scales into battle
and veiled it valyrian still sword
blackfire his crown was a simple circlet
of valyrian steel
set with big square cut rubies aegon
fathered two sons with his sister wives
his older son aenes was born to rhaenys
in 7ac
and in 12ac wizania bore his younger son
maegor
later known as meg or the crew but back
to aegon's early days
the first major event in his life was
helping and the attempt by volantis to
conquer the other three cities
using his dragon to support the forces
of braavos tyrosh and the westerosi
storm king
in driving the volunteens from lees and
mir
in doing so he confirmed that he had no
interest in reforging a valyrian empire
in essos
aegon then began planning the invasion
of westeros long before launching the
attack
spending time incognito visiting the
ciros's cities and castles
and gaining intelligence on different
houses their lords and their vessels
he was helped in the planning by his
half-brother born out of edlock
or his baratheon his most loyal ally in
vessel
his best friend and the first hand of
the king when the king of
air gilak the arrogant offered aegon an
alliance against hair in the black
offering his daughter's hand in marriage
to cement the deal
aegon declined and instead offered
orris's hand in marriage
argilac took that as an insult and cut
off the hands of fagon zenmoy
aegon used this as a justification for
his invasion of westeros
aegon his two sister wives and their
three dragons led a scanned few thousand
troops in invading the entire continent
of westeros
aegon fortified his initial landing
point at the northern shore of the mouth
of the blackwater river
strategically very defensible position
protected to the east and south by water
and surrounded by open plains which
would expose any attacking army long
before it arrived
shortly after landing his sister wife
wizenya crowned him king of
all westeros and shield of his people
titles he later discarded after his
second coronation in oldtown
despite being vastly outnumbered aegon
was able to secure victory after victory
using his dragons
the targaryen siblings departed to
aegonfort we take on marching northwest
into the riverlands to confront
harrenhorn
edmund tully lured the river and
declared for aegon
and led the riverlords in revolt against
the rolling ironborn
when heron refused to yield harehole
aegon attacked a gigantic
new castle with valerian and household
was extinguished with the burning of
harrenhal
the next day aegon named edmund as lord
paramount of the trident
meanwhile reigning senoris defeated the
randoms in the last storm
while visenya fought the arraigns and
secured the cracklot point
after regathering at stone except the
targaryen siblings advanced against the
larger host of the two kings
king mirn gardner of the reach and king
lorin lannister of the rock
the targaryen dragons valerian myrixis
and vogar allowed the aegon
to achieve a great victory at the field
of fire which resulted in the death of
mern the ninth gardener
and the surrender of lauren the first
lannister aegon then marched for
highgarden
where he named harlan tyrell as lord
paramount after the castle surrender
the targaryens again reunited to face
the host of torren stark
the king in the north but tauren chose
to kneel to aegon
along the trident instead of fighting a
battle and sacrificing dozens of
thousands
of north men for the lost cons visenya
returned to the vale
where she achieved the surrender of the
orients while reigns flew to dorne in an
unsuccessful mission to make the
martel's bow
meanwhile aegon marched to old town
which was surrendered to him by lord
manfred hightower
upon the advice of the high septon
within the stairs sapped the high septon
declared aegon to be the king of the
andals
the rhoynar and the first men lord of
the seven kingdoms and protector of the
realm
aegon chose to make his seed king's
landing a new settlement growing around
the aegon fort
he took the swords of his defeated
enemies forging them into the iron
throne
aegon also began what would become known
as the small council as well as that of
the hand of the king
with lord doris baratheon becoming his
first hand
aegon's first established law was the
king's peace which forbids conflict in
the realm
without the leave of the armed round
aegon treated the defeated lords with
respect
and allowed each region to retain its
own laws and customs
aegon often traveled around with six
maesters who educated him on each
region's local customs and history
in 2ac aegon turned his attention to the
iron islands
where the ironborn had been fighting for
two years over the kingship
aegon landed on great back with valerian
and the war fleet
to deal with the contenders again
personally cut down quarren walmart with
blackfyre
while the priests king lotus walked into
the sea drowning himself
the other contenders quickly bent the
knee aegon allowed the ironborn to name
their own lord paramount
for which the ironborn chose beacon
greyjoy as lord of the iron islands
despite a highly successful reign aegon
did face considerable problems
and none were as difficult to deal with
as the first dornish war
in 3ac aegon turned his attention back
on dorne
the only kingdom remaining unconquered
he first decided to try and bring dorne
under the rule of the iron throne
through diplomacy
after a year of negotiations and no
progress to show for it all though
aegon decided to take dorne by force of
arms
in 4ac aegon launched a new invasion
continuing the wars of conquest although
initially the conquest of dornes seemed
to succeed
it unraveled quickly and the first dorne
shore prolonged and lasted for nine
years
and knew many deaths and tragedies one
of these tragedies was the capture and
mutilation of aegon's friend
and the hand of the king lordor is
baratheon
by the veil of well following his
release from two years of captivity oris
returned home
lacking a swordhand aegon intent on
revenge released his dragons
and burned the castles of defiant
dornish lords
in 7ac aegon became a father for the
first time
when his younger sister wife rhaenys
gave birth to a son
amy's the greatest law sagan faced was
the death of queen reigning targaryen at
hellholt in 10 ac
when marxists fell from the sky with
rainies upon her back
after a shot from a scorpion took the
dragon in the eye
the war took a different turn after this
aegon's fury and grief had the loss of
his rifles such
that he headed for dorne himself
accompanied by visenya the last two
targaryens reigned fire upon the desert
strongholds
to break the dornish the next two years
were known as the dragon's road
a period when every dornish castle fell
the fury of the dragon riders
the only castle spared was sunspear the
seat of house mortal
in hopes that the dornish would turn
against their liege lords
the strategy failed and dorne remained
unconquered
in 11ac queen visenya announced her
pregnancy
and the next year she gave birth to
aegon's second son maegor
memphis says miriam martel died in 13ac
her son prince nymore sued for peace
having grown weary of war he sent his
daughter diriya with the skull of
marxists and a letter with her
took his landing to treat with the
conqueror the peace demanded by dorne
was peace between two sovereign kingdoms
not between a liege and his vessel
although aegon heard her
out against the advice of his advisors
such as auris and mizenia
he apparently decided to refuse the
request for peace
before he could speak diria mounted the
iron throne
and placed the letter from her father in
his hand
what was in the letter is unknown but
tagon's hand was so clenched around it
that it started to bleed he burned the
letter and left on valerian for
dragonstone the next morning he returned
and signed the peace treaty proposed by
the prince of dorne
recognizing it as a sovereign kingdom
historians suspect that neymar had
revealed to aegon that rhaenys was still
alive
and badly injured from falling off
marxist and that he would end her
suffering if the conqueror agreed to
peace
however i do not believe this to be true
because aegon kept good relations with
princess diaria
afterward perhaps his sister survived
the fall
and she delivered her to aegon on
dragonstone he even visited sunspear
with his eldest son prince aeneas in
23ac
to celebrate the 10th anniversary of the
peace between the iron throne and dorne
anyways the conqueror was almost killed
by assassins in the streets of king's
landing
and was only saved by visenya this led
to creation of the kingsguard
but its first member chosen by vizegna
to protect her brother husband with
their lives
the remaining 24 years of aegon's reign
were peaceful
so much that the last two decades of his
reign were later called the dragon's
peace
by the maesters of the citadel he spent
much of his time consolidating his power
by traveling throughout the seven
kingdoms
and building his capital at king's
landing in 37 ac on dragonstone
while telling his two eldest grandsons
say gonna miseries the tales of his
conquest at the painted table
aegon died from a stroke at the age of
64. aegon was cremated on dragonstone
and his funeral pyre was set aflame by
vergar
blackfire was burned along with him but
later retrieved from the pyre by maegor
this is the story of a legendary ear
mythical figure aegon to conquer
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comment section down below
once again house of the dragon a game of
thrones prequel about house targaryen is
coming in 2022
on hbo thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed this video please give it a
big thumbs up and i hope to see you in
the next one
peace